you guys are not gonna believe it team
avatar is back welcome back everyone
happy new year it's Charlie we have to
talk about the new avatar the last
airbender Netflix series there's new
episodes that are coming they're getting
ready to go into production so we'll
break it all down this will also be my
top 10 WTF moments from the series so if
you're brand new to my channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Avatar The
Last Airbender videos of course I'll be
doing episode videos for this series but
I'll also be doing bonus videos while we
wait for episodes to get here I'll think
of some fun avatar themed giveaway to do
for my avatar videos in the future but
big things first what's going on with
the new Netflix episodes so we got that
first look teaser of Appa they did say
that Appa was one of the few things that
they were really trying to nail early in
the production process they've written
all the scripts which is why they're
getting ready to start shooting the
script part was actually the easy stuff
because they're adapting the original
episodes just expanding the original
episodes from the 30-minute format to
the hour-long format because Netflix
seasons typically wind up being between
8 and 13 episodes obviously that means
structurally they'll have to change the
way they plot out book 1 book 2 and book
3 because it would be a super huge
bummer if they had to blow through all
that story in three seasons of only 8 to
13 episodes so the first two years of
the show we'll just be book 1 split into
two halves they didn't say whether it'd
be eight episodes 10 or 13 the reason
why the episode count will probably be a
little bit shorter per season like say
closer to 8 episodes is because Netflix
shows with huge special effects budgets
like Avatar The Last Airbender will need
to have so that they can do bending
right typically have shorter episode
runs The Witcher Netflix is a good
example of that they only did 8 episodes
because it's a super expensive show some
of the former avatar people said that
they're shooting the show in February so
I know a lot of you are like how do I
submit myself for casting because last
year Bryan Konietzko also revealed that
they would have open casting calls so if
you want a chance to star in Avatar The
Last Airbender there would be an
opportunity for that but he hasn't given
the details for that yet and typically
you would do that through Nickelodeon
studios but because this is a Netflix
project it'll probably be through one of
Netflix's companies that it selects for
that but big reminder because they're
trying to be as authentic to the
original story as possible
they're trying to be ethnically
authentic to what each of the nations
represents especially for the main
characters so for instance the Fire
Nation characters are based on Japanese
characters so the actors who play Fire
Nation characters will probably look
Japanese earth nation is mostly Qing
Dynasty Chinese even though the air
nation is mostly modeled after Tibetan
monks there aren't a ton of airbenders
during the original Avatar The Last
Airbender series because of the genocide
that's why the series is called The Last
Airbender because Aang is very literally
the last airbender until he starts his
own family with Katara in the water
nation are mostly modeled after the
inuit people it probably won't premiere
until 2021 though there was some
information that people found on
Netflix's website that listed 2020 as
the release date but that just does not
seem realistic most TV series take a
year to turnaround especially special
effects heavy TV shows like Avatar The
Last Airbender is going to be so getting
into my top 10 WTF moments from the show
and because they're doing this on
Netflix there are no broadcast standards
they can get way more hardcore with the
versions of these that they do on the
live-action Netflix series so starting
book number 10 egg learns what happened
to the airbenders after he was trapped
in the ice a hundred years ago the air
nomads genocide in the moments before he
finds out he has all these flashbacks
thinking about the happy memories that
he's going to try and relive and
reconnect with monk gyatsu but because
he's a child he's forgotten that it's
been a hundred years and most of them
would be dead in present-day anyway even
if they hadn't been killed off during
the war he binds the bones of monk
gyatsu and completely loses his [ __ ]
going into the Avatar state
automatically it's one of the first
times that happens on the show the very
first time he went into the Avatar state
was when he went into the ice a hundred
years ago and because he hasn't mastered
all the four major bending styles he
can't consciously
go into the Avatar state so when he does
Hulk out and go into it automatically
he's not in control of himself he
becomes literally like the mindless
version of the Hulk but number nine
princess uas death in the end of book 1
the siege of the north she was a
relatively new character but they did a
really good job of creating a
relationship between her and the other
characters Premier Li Sokka
so he actually did care about her when
it came time for her to choose to make
her sacrifice to save the moon spirit
the
whole metaphor being that the moon
spirit gave part of its life force to
save her as a child so she was
effectively returning that gift to the
moon spirit to bring it back to life
number eight Aang is forced into the
Avatar State after general Fung tricks
him into thinking that he killed Katara
so general Fung was meant to be a
different kind of villain or antagonist
however II want to think about him he
was someone who was trying to be a
friend this is a good thing go into the
Avatar State defeat Fire Lord Ozai now
and the war but this was happening way
before he learned to Earthbend or
firebend so he still couldn't go into
the Avatar State at will when he thinks
Katara has died though he hooks out
again in just like the Hulk does he
almost smashes everything in sight until
they bring him back down
number seven Aang meets code the face
dealer who appeared several times on the
show and was creepy in the best possible
way every single time the first time he
meets him and you see all the different
faces - you find that some of the faces
also represent some of the things that
Aang is going to encounter later in the
story like the blue Oni face which is
reminiscent of the Blue Spirit mask worn
by Zuko there's the face of the owl
which makes you think of Wan Shi Tong
which Aang will encounter later when he
eventually makes it to the library but
also you've learned the tragedy of
avatar Couric's fiance
how did Coe wind up stealing her face so
that became a big question for fans and
you also have to imagine that Coe lied a
little bit about his encounter with
avatar Karuk saying that he'd faced him
around 800 years ago when really it was
closer to 400 years ago
spirits lie all the time in the Avatar
series number 6 was when Appa got
abducted during book 2 when they were at
the library and forced to go into the
circus not only did it completely mess
aang up but it totally messed up Momo
and the rest of the group Appa gets
stolen by sandbenders when they're at
wan-chi tong's library which obviously
is a whole big thing all by itself
that's a completely separate thing
because the library is sinking into the
sand they're trying to stop it but also
while that's going on Appa gets stolen
and you don't see him for most of the
season once they get to Ba Sing se they
do an episode called oppas lost days
which literally tells you the story of
what happened to him while he's been
gone then it winds up being Zuko to find
him under the lake setting him free
so number 5 Zuko gives that the Blue
Spirit identity and set
Appa free it was one of the huge turning
points for his character he'd shown
signs of maybe starting to turn good
earlier in book 2 because Iroh had
really started to enjoy their life at
the tea shop embossing say hey we could
have a good life here why don't you just
chill out and abandon your search for
the avatar your father is probably never
going to love you anyway no matter what
you do up to this point Zuko had been
obsessed with capturing the avatar and
reclaiming his honor thinking that it
would finally make fire lord ozai loved
him because that's really what he wanted
his lost honor for the first couple of
seasons was more of a metaphor for the
lost love between him and Fire Lord Ozai
of all the main characters Zuko has
probably the most tragic backstory which
is why he's one of the best characters
in television history and has one of the
greatest redemption arcs in television
history but number four WTF the story of
how suco got his scar so the reason he
was actually scarred was because he was
speaking out against the Fire Nation
generals when they were going to cause a
lot of unnecessary collateral damage to
Fire Nation soldiers during this
upcoming attack but Fire Lord Ozai took
it as an insult to him even though Zuko
wasn't speaking to him directly he was
forced into the Agni Kai to answer for
his perceived insult but then found out
that it was his father he was going to
fight and when Zuko refused to fight him
throwing himself at his feet Ozai
scarred him permanently number three was
when aang died for a little while during
the book 2 finale after Azula lightning
bends him while he's in the Avatar state
they had established the rules for how
you kill avatars earlier if you die
while you're in the Avatar state you
won't reincarnate and it will end the
Avatar cycle but just in general avatars
can be killed like any other person
being in the Avatar State doesn't make
them invincible it just gives them a
great deal more power it was a huge
moment for the show because we're
talking about Nickelodeon here you don't
expect them to kill off their main
character in such a WTF moment typically
you expect that from stuff on HBO like
Game of Thrones when they killed off Jon
Snow but even though he came back at the
beginning of book 3 he did legit die for
a little while it wasn't like they were
trying to fake it or he was on the edge
of death he really did die number 2 the
tale of Iroh in his son Lu 10 so Iroh
also one of the best characters in TV
history partly because he also has one
of the most tragic backstories and best
story arcs in TV history and his arc
is very similar to the arc that Zuko
goes on during the main series but IRA
went through a lot of those motions in
the events set before the series begins
so you have to remember that IRA was
born as fire Lord a salons oldest son
and he was first to the line to become
the Next Fire Lord he was a good soldier
a great general but his devotion to the
military and their conquest of the other
Four Nations cost him his relationship
with his son Lew 10 and eventually Luton
was killed in battle with the earth
nation a couple years before the
beginning of the series the event caused
I road to have the same type of
existential crisis the zoo Co has on the
main show questioning his beliefs
turning him down the path of goodness
eventually he joined the order of the
White Lotus and became a force for good
also sort of adding to the WTF nature of
Zuko's family when this was all
happening and he was grieving for his
dead son Ozai used it as an opportunity
to usurp iroh's place in the line of
succession so that he would jump the
line and become the next Fire Lord
all of iroh's history plays out during
the tales of Ba Sing se episode during
book 2 it's one of the best episodes of
the series and one of the best episodes
of any television show in history a lot
of you may have guessed my number one
WTF so number one the story of what
happened to Zuko's mother
Zucco's backstory is all the more tragic
because his mother's backstory is also
just as tragic one of the reasons why
Zuko's mother is really special is
because she was descended from the line
of Avatar Roku Avatar Roku was married
he had a family with children before he
was killed by his former friend Fire
Lord Sozen
like they say sozin's comet sozin's son
as Alon who's the father of Fire Lord
Ozai forced Ursa to marry Ozai in order
to fill a prophecy about a royal
descendent bringing great power to their
family's bloodline Fire Lord
Aslan assumed that this was literal
power and mixing the blood of his family
with the blood of the former avatars
family would do that so Ursa has already
forced into an unhappy marriage when she
is young she's constantly mistreated by
Ozai who slowly becomes more and more
evil with his desire for power and world
domination until eventually she winds up
killing Fire Lord
Azlan after she finds out that he had
ordered Ozai to kill Zuko she makes a
bargain to spare Zuko's life with Ozai
in exchange for her going into hiding
for the rest of her life in banishment
and because Zuko was so young she didn't
really get the
chance to explain why all this was
happening or say goodbye to him before
she left so later OHS I lied to Zuko
about why she left making him think that
she had abandoned him as a child because
she didn't love him
adding to the tragedy of his backstory
it does have a bit of a happy ending she
was eventually able to find happiness
maybe I'll do a future video about what
happened to Zuko's mother they kind of
deal with that during the comics though
after the main series and even though it
didn't fit on my top 10 list we do have
to talk about Katara blood bending one
of the most WTF moments I hope they're
able to do that justice when they get to
the live-action version but everyone let
me know what your favorite WTF moment
from Avatar The Last Airbender and leave
all your requests for Avatar bonus
videos click here to learn about their
original plans for Avatar The Last
Airbender season 4 when they thought
that they were going to do season 4 and
click here for all my new Mandalorian
and baby Yoda season 2 videos thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome happy new year
[Music]